the Joe Rogan experience a live a movie
poster from the night cuz I'd much
rather see the old Godzilla's Godzilla
vs. mortal eye versus the smog monster
Godzilla just to see what Japanese
people were doing yeah they had the
string on them they would do wide shot
so they would show the Chinese people
running and then they would just have a
single shot Godzilla moving through the
air yeah they're Japanese I'm Japanese
look how dopey looks look even wits lit
up that is [ __ ] fun man that's fun
look he's going through the [ __ ]
Electric God so let us give a [ __ ] the
shooting um [ __ ] you yes you know they
can't show you a behind shot of the
Japanese shooting Godzilla cos there's
really no God they just shoot into a
wall it's completely separate this is
like a real claim model if you look at
it he's really not sixty feet it's maybe
[ __ ] eight inches or something no
this is not a model these are men in
suits this is the difference between
King Kong and the oh [ __ ] yes these are
men in suits and it's really complicated
and these guys had to be really strong
cuz they're carrying around this
gigantic rubber suit and it's heavy it's
[ __ ] hot as [ __ ]
so the reason why it moves so fluid what
the Japanese did that was brilliant
was they had men and they put men in
these monster suit looks just a [ __ ]
buggers not yeah go in now Google the
men who wore the Godzilla suit it's
actually pretty [ __ ] cool it's not
easy to do these guys had to walk around
and have these fight scenes and [ __ ] in
these big giant suits that wasn't
animation that's a dude in there
this isn't that crazy and that's that's
what it really looked like in terms of
height wise it's like the size of a
person see that guy go back a bit you
see that guy getting out of it that
right there that's what the dude looked
like who's inside of it he burned them
who thought it was like a clay model no
no King Kong's a clay model King Kong
was claymation
from Ray Harryhausen that's how I got
onto the subject with them I was telling
them about they loved that Monsters Inc
show and Harry Hewson is one of the
characters or something about Harry
using his in the movie I said huh I go
do you guys know that is and they don't
know I said that is the guy who of
course they didn't know who it is well
[ __ ] my talking about but I said that's
the guy who was one of the original
monster animators for for movies like
King Kong he did all that claymation
stuff and back then I mean that was the
state of the art you gotta think
nineteen [ __ ] thirty something I was
like King Kong's about thirty three yeah
Godzilla that was later that was
post-world War two yeah see you got it
5450 for post post World War two was
Godzilla
Godzilla's after we we shouldn't say we
somebody from the United States drop
bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki when
they used nuclear weapons the idea was
that and all the nuclear tests that they
had done in the water there was no real
understanding of what the [ __ ] was gonna
happen and so the science fiction
version of that would be that all that
radiation would create some super
monster welcome brilliant yeah the man
the Japanese I gotta give it to him they
were dealing with radiation poisoning
and death on unbelievable on an
unbelievable scale I mean hundreds of
thousands of people wiped out instantly
from atomic bombs I mean and so the just
a sheer force of the power of those
things you couldn't even imagine that
there could be anything that could do
that just one thing that falls out of an
airplane that can do that well what else
can it do you know well what happens if
it gets in the water what is it how's
this chicken affect fish how's it gonna
affect you know who knows so the the
science fiction version was always
awesome they're like a Godzilla would
come that's what the new ones about to
write anyone is same kind of thing like
a dinosaur got zapped and now that I
believe the new one was all the other
dinosaurs came back and they had to
reawaken Godzilla because he is the only
thing that can fight him he's a super
superhero never bring him back he's a
good guy in this one oh no he's not a
good guy at the end of the last and
everyone complained because there's like
this weird Winky scene where like
Godzilla and the main guy like looked at
each other in the eye or like same team
bro you know the real Godzilla's man the
real Godzilla Circe's are not Cersei
that what the folks are named the dragon
mother of dragons dragon and the game of
Thrones
that [ __ ] up that city at the end like
that's that's what a like a real that's
a real horrific idea of a fire-breathing
lizard but Godzilla was always adorable
didn't really go after people even the
early even the early Superman's the
first like six episodes you could see
the string really check it out that's a
little black and white this is my violet
maybe the pilot in the first three
episodes so they figured out how he
could do it
you could see his train it's a weird the
Godzilla stories a weird story right
because it's not like Godzilla goes on a
killing spree it just goes through Tokyo
and just starts lighting every building
on fire he doesn't do that he's like
almost like he is almost like a good guy
lizard and in the new movie it's more
accentuated then so he has to help help
us and Lola was the [ __ ] bird Mothra
was a moth more tremors a moth yeah and
what was the smog monster caravan there
look like I'm trying to remember like
wings and [ __ ] right didn't Rodin have
wings you got again this is crazy this
[ __ ] oh that's right lobe Rodin could
fly look at that one with the blue sky
below on three oh there's a three-headed
one yeah but this is new monsters no
these are the new ones the new what the
[ __ ] outta here with this new [ __ ] give
me the blue sky right there with that
yeah right there oh that's kind of TV
show it was the smog monster had laser
beams coming out of his [ __ ] eyes
like Medusa yes he did yeah one of them
bad [ __ ] laser beam did you really
oh my god the three-headed things that
was that called again I forgot about
that three head in the King Ghidorah
say that Oh Ghidorah Mozart wrote damn
it was Ghidorah
yeah just pull up a video of Godzilla
versus Gaeta
it was so silly but man when we were
little kids this [ __ ] yeah
lose your mind I used to love dishes the
best when you found out Godzilla's gonna
be on TV or so pumped from the actual
new movies oh there's a new movie with
Keeler so it's not that this movie is
out right now
it is it Godzilla king of the monsters
yeah that's why I ain't brothers in this
all three of these are let me see these
[ __ ] whoa special effects today's oh
my god - the special effects they can do
today are insane so we're looking at it
says King gh I do RA H King Ghidorah oh
my god dude the [ __ ] special effects
are insane there's Mothra Wow is this
supposed to be a good movie though the
thing is with these movies is and I
really hate to say this how come they
can't do both how come they can't have
animate amazing special of 40 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes how come they can't have
amazing special effects and a [ __ ]
killer story no I can't they do that
that's one of the last of the great 2009
is 10 years ago yeah which one was that
an avatar avatar was a great story with
great special effects
[Applause]